Calling all Viper pilots, the galaxies on the edge of doom again.
This is Lifeforce.
Nostalgia And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Joe.
And I'm Sean. And we are playing the first ever, quote unquote, sequel to a essential game.
Ooh. Oh, yeah.
We've played Ikari Warriors 2, so we have some, we've dabbled in sequels.
Has anybody ever seen a sequel to a movie or played another game that had a sequel?
You know what? I actually have.
They're usually similar.
Got it. And so that would make sense why they usually don't call them just the game 2, right?
They usually give it a totally different name.
Yeah, I was just going to say this one, never would have known.
Like, yeah, like The Dark Knight.
Yeah. The Dark Knight Rises.
Yeah, which was, yeah, that's true.
That was a sequel to a movie.
Yeah, they didn't call it The Dark Knight 2.
That's right. They called it The Dark Knight Rises.
And I'm talking about Life Force, which is a sequel to Gradius.
Yes, that's right. Don't let people tell you otherwise.
If they say that it's not true, that's because they're talking about the arcade game, which was also known as Salamander, but for all intents and purposes is the same game.
However, it's only on the NES box where Konami finally decides to say, oh, yeah, this is the same exact universe because they put here, you've saved the innocent people of Gradius.
That's like automatically enough for me.
That's evidence. I think it's just like a coincidence.
You've saved the innocent people of Gradius from the vile bacterians, but now an even deadlier plague has, I thought it said smiled, it says slimed, has slimed into the neighborhood.
What happened there?
I don't know. Is that a verb?
To get slimed, you know?
That was also like a very like normal sci-fi thing to say at the top and then met like with fellow kids at the end, you know?
Guess who just slimed into the neighborhood?
Good. It's the Zelos.
It's all right because like the whole plot to this game, at least in the manual, is word salad.
Like there's nothing.
They use words wrong.
They make up words.
And all they had to do was say, oh, no, he's back.
But we did get the meaningful line in bold.
The birth of Zelos could mean the death of zillions.
They might as well just said zillions at that point.
But maybe that would have been citizens of Zelos.
It's never really clear what Zelos is other than like a...
It's a little boy.
Like a snake, right? It's a little boy monster.
No, it's not a little boy.
It's a little boy monster.
Okay. It's like an adult space monster is how it's described.
He grew into an adult space monster.
Oh, he started out as a little boy.
Got it. It's been a while.
Zelos is hearty.
Yeah. His proud parents, Ma and Pa Deltoid, named their only son Zelos.
It's like they couldn't decide if they wanted it to be like really cool or really funny.
Do you know what Zelos means though in their language?
What? One mean son of a gun.
Oh, yeah. I gotta say that when they wrote this, like as Zelos grew into an adult space monster,
his appetite turned ravenous, his temper became ruthless, and his name proved an understatement.
I gotta imagine that the writer just was so happy with himself.
Yeah, I think he was like cracking his knuckles before he wrote it.
Like, here we go. Typing away.
And you're back in the Vic Viper, which was in Gradius as well and will be in all future
Gradius-like games.
There's a weird thing here though, and I don't know if Sean threw this in because he's sponsored
by Lazy Boy, but it says here that a pilot can pull 600 Gs at a warp speed.
That's bullshit. What?
It's all nonsense.
But then, I mean, like that stuff's all cool.
Like, if you're a kid, that stuff helps, right?
Right, 600 Gs, warp speed 9.
Those are exciting things.
Makes total sense. Then saying, it's like he's lounging in a Lazy Boy.
TM. I think, yeah, I think it's either a TM or an R.
Whatever. It's amazing that they included that.
Yeah, and I just, I think that actually lounging in a Lazy Boy isn't cool compared to going
600 G and warp speed 9.
It should be like you're in the cockpit or something.
You can recline the Lazy Boy, and that's kind of like, it's kind of like an adventure.
Yeah, it's like he's snoozing.
Yeah, he's flying. And outside of the Vic Viper, then there's the Road British Space Destroyer.
It's funny how like these don't sound like they were named, but I mean, I guess they're
not, but it just sounds, they don't sound like they were named by the same team.
I mean, I think the Road British, I read that it's a translation error.
It's supposed to be the Lord British.
Yes, that's true.
But it's just weird to think that in the Gradius timeline, which I think is there in like the
year 3000 or maybe even much, much later.
Yeah. It's weird to think that like the British Empire is still like referenced in any capacity.
Exactly. Thousands of years later.
I assumed it was like supposed to be the rogue British space destroyer.
It was a rogue British space destroyer.
Gotcha. Okay. Well, that was just an assumption.
If you somehow have not played Gradius or didn't listen to our episode, which I highly recommend,
we were very kind to Gradius, I'll just give a brief overview here.
The NES version of this game, Life Force, is treated as a sequel to Gradius in both the
things we were just talking about, but also gameplay wise.
It's important to note that the original arcade version of Salamander, as the game was
known, did not play like Gradius.
It was only once the name got changed to Life Force that it played a lot similar to Gradius.
So what does that mean? Well, it usually means that it's a horizontal style shmup, but Life Force adds vertical layouts
as well. So it alternates between horizontal stages and vertical stages, A, B, A, B.
You have to successfully
survive traversing through the six different stages.
And at the end of each stage, there's a mandatory boss that must be defeated in order to move forward.
Unlike in Gradius, there are cut scenes between the levels rather than continuing to just progress
on after you defeat the boss, the screen would just start scrolling again.
That's not true here.
In this one, you do get a moment to breathe.
And the power-up section from Gradius returns with even more choices this time.
And the power-ups, the way that system worked in Gradius that we were big fans of was every
time you collect a power-up, you store a level, and then you decide to cash in.
So a level one power-up is for a speed boost, and a level six is for a force field, essentially.
So if you wait to collect six power-ups, you can cash in and get the force field, or you
can just continuously increase your speed.
And they stack, whether it's within that single power-up or in total.
You can be super fast, have the shield, have the lasers, or you can just keep going faster
and faster. So, yeah.
And was that power-up system also present in the arcade version then?
It was not. So that's the major thing.
It's a whole different game.
The major thing that made it different was that when you collected power-ups in Salamander,
you immediately received the next upgrade of your ship.
So the layout would continue to change as you got the power-up.
So you've grabbed the first one, and it's an option.
And then you grab the second one, and now you have missiles, so on and so forth.
It was a little weirder, but I think it's nice that the NES version...
Streamlines it for people who are interested in games after Gradius.
Choice and everything. Yeah. So what did we like so much about Gradius?
I think a big part of it was that power-up system, at least for me.
Just the ability to kind of choose your power-ups and almost have this real-time RPG decision-making
going on. And that's...
To be honest, when I was playing this game, I kind of forgot a lot about how much I liked
that about Gradius. I had to go back and watch a little bit of Gradius to be like, wow, that is what that
was like. Yeah.
I think that the creative use of the power-up system was my main selling point for Gradius.
And also just the performance and how it looked in comparison to everything else that we were
playing around that time.
It just seemed a step above.
So all that together just seemed like the perfect NES game at the time.
Yeah. I remember we even commented about the Vic Viper and the way that as you moved from up
and down the screen, you actually saw different angles of your ship.
And that's here too.
So that was nice.
But yeah, it's definitely about the control of the ship itself and how smooth everything
plays out. The graphics are a huge plus as well.
But I really liked Gradius for the traversal style of thoughtful level design that you're
actually going through either a cave or a space war zone.
It's not just waves of enemies.
There's also this design to the map that you're on that requires you to think about where you
want to be on the stage.
And there's obstacles in the way other than just outright enemies.
So that's what I really liked about Gradius.
Now looking ahead to Life Force, the game of the week that we've played.
We're playing Life Force? Yeah, Life Force.
I know. We've been saying Salamander.
We've been saying Gradius.
It's all over the place.
Just like the manual, this has been word salad a little bit.
So let's just focus in for the remainder of our time, focusing on Life Force.
And I'd really like to just start talking about the refined controls here and the improved
graphics because it seems kind of silly to be talking about graphics on the NES when
we have what we have today.
But I do think that when you compare Gradius and this, a game that we already thought was
pretty good looking, this is a step up and it also feels a little faster.
I wouldn't say they changed the way that the Vic Viper controls in a meaningful way.
It just feels faster, the game overall.
I'll jump in to talk about the graphics real quick too because that's something that stood
out to me right away.
And it's not even necessarily graphics as much as it is just, I guess, like art style
and design. But similar to what you said about Gradius, Mike, is that, or Sean, I can't remember who
said it, but that it stands out even now, even this much further into it, it stands out
a little bit as like having these environmental things that make you feel like you're
in this specific space that it wants you to feel like.
Not that we haven't had other games like that, but too many times we see a game that it's
just like, you're just flying, enemies are coming at you, and there's just basic environments
around. Yeah, just like a scrolling, repeating, like archipelago below you, or it's just a star field.
Like, yeah, I appreciate that these are each actual places.
Even just out of shmups, just to take it into a very popular game, The Legend of Zelda, each
of those dungeons doesn't, you know, there wasn't yet the concept of a water dungeon and
a forest dungeon.
There was the blue dungeon and the green dungeon.
Right. But the layout-wise, they were all still the same.
So what helped that, obviously, was that the puzzles were unique and different.
But, you know, that is something to keep in mind, that this really, the idea of taking
place inside of a living planet that you're trying to get to the center of and defeat,
what was his name, Zelos?
Zelda. Yeah. Zelda.
The fact that you're trying to actually, like, put a narrative of, like, entering this living
planet and then going inside of its...
Shrinkter. Yeah.
Well, yeah, sure.
Whatever it is.
But, you know, there's a cool conceit there.
And then when you get to, like, the volcanoes and the fire spitting out...
Solar flares, yeah. Which are horrible, but they're awesome.
Like, it adds that level to what you were talking about before, where the environment
is, like, a part of the game.
They're the obstacles. You're interacting with the environment.
It feels like you're in a living thing.
And knowing that these are ports of an arcade game, too, just to talk again about how good
they look, they look different enough from the way they look in the arcade that,
you know it's an NES game and then it's not trying to just figure out, like, okay, what's
the 8-bit equivalent of what the arcade game looks like?
But it almost takes on its own design spin.
And I think that really helps it rather than, you know, Double Dragon in recent memory.
Like, not that that game looked bad, but it didn't look like its arcade counterpart,
but it was just trying to mimic everything that you saw.
Whereas this would make some sacrifices.
I also think that this, like, the NES versions of these games do have a unique look to them
compared to other games in general, not just other shmups.
And maybe that's just because I enjoyed these more.
But to me, they look much different than a lot of the shovelware we played.
And I can't put my finger on it, really, because we've played other games that look,
I'd say, you know, as good.
But something about this and Gradius, when I played both of them, the first thing I thought
was, like, wow, this almost looks a little like Super Nintendo.
I don't know what it is, if it's, like, the brightness of the colors contrasted against,
like, the black backgrounds or something.
But something about it is, like, wow, this looks like it's, like, up a level a little bit.
Well, one specific example that really impressed me was the reveal of the first boss,
where you're in the middle of, again, it looks like intestines to me.
And then all of the different sprites for the walls around you just sort of fade away
and it morphs into or just reveals this big brain.
Yeah, and it fades away in such, like, a slow way.
Yeah, in a really organic way.
That you're almost like, is it fading away?
For a second, you're, like, questioning, is that fading away?
And then it just, like, you don't even see it happening, just slowly there just is a brain there.
Yeah, it was really impressive. Almost all of the bosses are really good-looking, too, from, like, a pixel art perspective
because they're the only other layer.
They basically even remove the HUD during the boss fights
to make sure that they can design the bosses as nice as they want to.
But also, they're very creative bosses from just a, you know,
from, like, a way that they design to attack you.
Yeah, there are different strategies.
And they're not outright, none of them are outright impossible.
No. They all have a very clear pattern that you have to follow.
And they kind of remind me of Stinger's bosses that were also very creative.
Like, there was that giant watermelon and stuff like that.
I love the saxophone. Yeah. And the saxophone that, I thought that was something else I remember.
Yeah, but it was a saxophone.
But, yeah, it was a saxophone.
But, you know, like, that stuff is really cool, and I'm glad that that's back here.
And what do I care if, like, one of them is an Egyptian, like, sarcophagus, you know?
Like, fine. It was Tutankhamen Attack.
That's his name. You're right.
Tutankhamen Attack. All one word.
There's, you know, I think that the boss fights in this one were even more enjoyable
than some of the, like, actual levels you had to go through because they're very approachable.
They feel good to defeat.
And there is, like, a solving process to the whole thing.
Yeah. At first, you're like, you know, and maybe it's not as hard.
Like, the brain is the first boss.
And obviously, he's very easy.
It's just, like, shoot the eye.
Yeah, shoot the eye.
And I like that one because that reminded me the most of Gradius' shoot the core.
Is this the one that has three different cores?
Or is this? Yeah, he has, well, no.
The three different cores one, I know what you're thinking of.
That's kind of like a sub-boss.
Yeah, that was. I'm looking at the pictures right now.
That's the one that has the, it's the ship from.
Yeah. That was at the end of every Gradius level.
Yeah, that's true. And you had to shoot the core, and that's where that phrase comes that's very, like, iconic to Gradius players.
The intruder was the only one that had to do that where you would shoot out the layers and then take it out.
Yeah, I like that shooting of layers.
It's very fun.
Yeah, and it was, again, like, the fact that he just shoots the, like, arms around, like, just swings his arms around in a circular motion.
It becomes very clear that you have to kind of, like, go clockwise with him.
You have to get on the inside, or else he's too fast.
If you're too far on the outside, he's too fast for you.
It's interesting. Right.
And all of these bosses are very well complemented by your power-up systems, too.
I think regardless of whether you have a fully loaded ship, like, let's say, with, you know, the double lasers and two options and a force field, like, all that stuff feels great when you're a fully decked out ship.
But even just having an additional option brings in this whole new level of strategy for whether you want to, like, double up and stay exactly in the same spot and just shoot, you know, like, twice the amount of fire at once.
Or if you want to cover more ground and be like, well, this boss keeps, like, I'm thinking of Tooting Common Attack, the Egyptian head, where he kind of just keeps going up and down on the horizontal stage.
So you can just leave your option there.
Right. You're out of harm's way.
Yeah, exactly. And just keep shooting.
So, yeah, it lends itself to a lot of creative thinking.
Yeah. Even another one just to call out that I liked was Giga, the, like, skull head thing.
Yeah. Because that is a boss battle that, for some reason, is very easy if you're fully decked out.
Yeah. It could take, like, maybe three to four hits before it dies for some reason.
But if you're not fully decked out, as time goes on, it then, like, seeks its eyeballs out at you.
Like, it's like, forget all this stuff that's coming out of my mouth.
Like, now its eyeballs start, like...
See, I thought, maybe it was just because it took me longer to defeat him than you were.
I thought maybe I wasn't able to kill him until his eyeballs came out because he didn't die for me until after his eyeballs came out and I started shooting at his eyeballs.
I've definitely had only...
I've had situations where only one eyeball came out and it was, like, not even all the way out.
So I think it is just a certain amount of hits.
I don't think it has to do with, like, waiting until the eyeballs come out.
Gotcha. Thank you.
Thank you.
Let's hear it.
front of or back of the screen for particular hazards ahead of time.
You won't have to deal with the problems.
But I never think a game should be reduced to memory.
We have been very hard on games that do that.
But it does sort of come with the territory with a lot of NES games.
So it's like, I think sometimes you might have to just get around it, but...
So in the very first stage, you're in what I would consider, like, the body of the planet.
Yeah. And it's growing.
It grows these, like, barriers of its intestines or whatever.
I like to...
I mean, I know you think it's just me being funny, but these are sphincters.
Okay. There you go. So they are...
These sphincters are growing barriers that, like, at a rate that almost might at first...
And I don't know if you guys had this experience.
I did. I thought, like, oh, something's wrong with the cartridge.
Like, it's not in all the way...
It's like... It didn't see those pixels until I got close to them.
Because it doesn't really, like, look like it's growing.
And they just kind of populate onto the screen.
And then there was one, all of a sudden, that just completely took over and closed off the entire screen.
And that's when I knew, like, oh, this isn't a glitch.
I'm just doing something wrong.
So then I tried shooting at it next time.
And it doesn't work either.
And that's when I realized, oh, you just have to know about it and be in front of it before it closes.
There were a few that I remember thinking, like, it starts happening and you're like, oh, gotta get through and you have time.
But there are some that it's like, if you weren't ready for it, like, it's pretty tough to get past.
So I think I'd like to see if I can predict your next one.
Which, is that the solar flares?
The solar flares are the next one.
So I would say that there's a difference between these two.
Because with the first, with the sphincters, I think it's more logical for the player to believe that these are things that are going to contract and expand as you go.
And you will never actually be blocked off entirely.
Like, I thought that, like, oh, it's closed for now, but it's going to open in a second.
And it never did.
Whereas, so it's not really telegraphing anything.
That's true. Whereas with the solar flares in level whatever.
I think it's the third one.
Okay, in level three. It does give you a split second of showing where it's going to come out from.
And I think that if you can read that quick enough and you've picked up enough speed power-ups to be able to react in time, you can get out of the way of these solar flares.
And absolutely true.
And I would say that this is one that was on my list.
And I thought maybe I should take it off because it is something that you can overcome.
And I definitely did wind up doing eventually a perfect run through that.
The thing there that bothers me is the split second thing that you were referring to.
I wish for, like, a little longer of a bubble up because there's already a lot going on on that screen.
And it's not, you know, if you're not paying attention to everything, like, imagine you have to watch, like, 40 different things going on.
And then all of a sudden, the little bottom hand, there's, like, a small little jiggle.
And then, boom. That's my second problem.
The wave of these solar flares is gigantic.
It covers so much real estate of the screen.
And it's a double-edged sword because it is beautiful sprite work.
You know, like, it looks really cool.
It's hecking awesome. Right.
It's really cool. So I don't know what I would have preferred them to do here.
I just think taking up so much of the real estate and playing in a way where you have to pretty much be in the middle of each one is a cool solve.
But maybe it shouldn't have been the entire level.
I think it's very annoying that there's, like, over 20 of these throughout the level.
Did you count? Yeah.
I mean, it goes on for a very long time.
So I'm going to say it felt like over 20.
Okay. I could have done five.
The reason I'm a little more forgiving that, too, because I do think that the telegraph for me was, like, almost not noticeable.
But the reason I'm a little more forgiving is because this one, at least, you might die once.
And then you're like, okay, I have to play this level really cautiously.
And you can play it that way.
You can stay to the back. And you can even wait until the soil fire appears and not get hit and kind of stay behind it.
Yeah. Whereas with the first one we talked about with the growing whatever, I don't want to say it.
No, I know. You mean the sphincters?
Exactly. They do – if you were to try and, like, be cautious and stay ahead of it, like, you might be too late.
Like, you have to, like, be aggressive and kind of know where they are.
Whereas this is, like – even if you don't know where the solar flares are coming, it just makes you think about the level differently.
Like, I've got to be careful.
That does its own – that has its own faults as well because you're also being harassed by – I think they're invincible?
Which – what is that?
Nothing in this stage, I believe, is invincible.
Oh, okay. Well, you're still being harassed by fighters that are coming at you that are not affected by the fire.
And then there's also those random firebirds because, like –
Oh, yeah, yeah. So there's five firebirds in a row and that will give you a power-up.
And that's normal. There's a specific orange-colored enemies in everywhere.
But then there's another one that I think Sean was just mentioning that if you shoot it, it just does, like, a kamikaze attack at you.
And it's like, whoa, you look like the same as the other ones.
Why are you going to start coming at me?
Why are you coming at me?
I don't like when the birds come at me, especially when they're orange, which in this game so far has only ever meant power-up.
Yeah. You know? This stage also has, I think, the only ability to get a power-up that's blue instead of orange that destroys everything on screen.
And maybe that was just because they were, like, after the fact, they were like, wow, we really put a lot of enemies in here.
We should get rid of them.
Like, there should be a way for the – you know, just in case they're all still on the screen.
We should have a way to just clear them all out at once.
Can you guess my next one?
I can't right now.
Is it in the pillar stage?
I have – The temple stage?
It's before the temple stage.
It's the parasitic brown roots.
They look like the tree roots.
Ah, yeah, yeah. That grow out of the, like, circular –
Orbs. Yeah, the orb bodies.
Okay. And the reason here, they expand way too fast.
It doesn't – it doesn't – it only basically rewards the player for just staying at the very bottom of the screen.
Well, yeah, I mean, that's the – that's what you're supposed to do in this part.
Yeah, this one didn't bother me, actually, because I don't know if I was always able to destroy those.
Yeah, I was always powerful enough in this stage that I was able to destroy it before I could even get in range.
Got it. So you're wrong, Mike.
Okay, that makes sense.
I can be wrong.
I'm cool with that.
But I had a problem with it.
It's okay. And – oh, and then this one was just kind of, like, prevailing throughout some of the stages.
But there was, like, sometimes these walls that were destructible.
And I'm not talking about in the temple because the temple one was the exception to this rule.
But there were some walls that were destructible and then they would regenerate.
But they regenerated, like, in a very weird timing manner.
So if you were hanging back and shooting at the wall, as you got closer to the wall, it might regenerate and close in on you.
Yeah. I know what you mean.
And it was, like, you kind of had to, like, know about that and be very close to the wall at all times.
This way you could constantly be shooting exactly what's ahead of you.
This way it wasn't on the timer.
Yeah, I could deal without that as well.
Yeah. You're correct.
Yeah, thank you. Thank you.
So I'm wrong and I'm right.
And I think this last one is just – this one's not necessarily bad.
It's pretty cool. Spoiler for the end of the game here.
After you defeat the final boss, you have to, like, escape the planet before it explodes.
And they make these, like, little gates that you essentially have to, like, get through.
And, you know, they're pretty much just making you zigzag.
And they're very, like, frame perfect.
It's so fast. That's what I was thinking of when I said the temple level.
I forgot that this is at the end of – not in the temple.
It's at the very end of the game.
Here's my problem with that, though.
By the end of the game, you're either on, like, one to two lives left or you have, like, ten.
You know, it depends on what kind of player you were if you were going for scoring because it's very easy to get extra lives in this game.
So I think it's just, like, what are you doing here at the end by killing off, like, in a perilous way here?
Because if you only have one to two lives left, it sucks to die right there.
You've kind of already beaten what, like, what you would think is the game.
And then there's this thing that's – it's cool to have an extra challenge, but, like you said, it is frame perfect.
But also if you –
Not literally, but it feels like it.
It feels like it also because it's so narrow.
I would have actually been fine with the idea of maybe it closing in, too.
And you have – like, there is a – there's another cave earlier on that you kind of imagine if you picked up speed or wind or something, like you went through a wind tunnel or something.
Space wind. It makes the whole thing go faster, though, you know?
Yeah. What would you call that?
Like, what would you call that effect?
It definitely does speed up the scrolling.
Yeah. So that would have been something cool, like having to navigate through asteroids or something like that.
But to have, like, these – this is your – there's only this very small width that's available to you.
And then immediately after that, it's, like, one frame over, one frame over.
It's like, no, don't do that.
Yeah. No, it's a – this is a very annoying part.
And this would be at the top of my list of things that were peeving me.
But the problem is double – you know, is double-sided here because forget the one to two having the game over thing.
If you have 10-plus lives, it's very anticlimactic as well because you might just die.
Plop room, yeah. And then you're – you know, the – one thing that hasn't been mentioned at all yet that's worth explaining is that when you die in this one –
I figured we'd get into that, yeah.
Right. You – rather – there's no checkpoint.
In Gradius, it would start you back at a certain checkpoint depending on where you were in the stage.
In Life Force here, you just immediately come back onto the screen, which I think is great.
Yeah. Except for here at this very ending because you wind up just coming back, crashing again, coming back, crashing again.
And then the next thing you know, it practically played out like a cut scene.
As long as you have more – I think I timed it.
As long as you have more than four lives, you don't have to move.
You'll die and pop up enough times that you'll be able to just then take off.
Interesting. Into the ending cut scene.
Yeah. I guess then it's not that big of a deal because it doesn't matter.
Right. But it feels kind of like something that was supposed to be epic, isn't it?
So there's really no solution here other than get rid of that, in my opinion.
And not to mention that the last boss sucks.
Yeah. It's the worst boss.
All the other bosses are great.
And then the box art made this snake-like creature look so cool, right?
He has these huge fangs.
The salamander? What?
The salamander? Yeah, the salamander.
Yeah. And it's so cool.
And then you see it on the screen, and you're like, I think I saw a bunch of those in the volcano level.
Right? Yeah.
Going back to what we sort of touched upon, which is that difficulty,
and this was the kind of, it's a riff off of the way they play with difficulty in Gradius,
where, you know, you can become all-powerful, pretty much,
but as soon as you get hit once, like, you're back to square one,
regardless of whether you're on level one, two, three, or if you're fighting a boss in this one.
I know that we've talked about being punished for doing well or being punished for doing badly.
Like, how did you find the difficulty in this game in general?
Well, I think I'm going to start off with the first part,
addressing that with the when you die and you come back with nothing.
That was handled a lot better here,
and I think that was because power-ups were more frequent other than just the beginning of the stage.
I think that was very important to at least give,
they definitely give less opportunities as the stage goes on,
and if you come back at the boss, you're out of luck.
But the ability to, you won't get a full ship again by the end of the level if you're in the middle of the level,
but the ability to go in, die, and come back with a chance to maybe even have, like, another option would be, you know,
is nice and appreciated.
So I actually found the difficulty in this game overall to be significantly easier than Gradius.
Oh, yeah. I found it easier than Gradius, too,
but I also found that I still felt like the power-ups were really weighted towards the first half of the level
and not the second half of the level.
Oh, yeah, they are. Where I feel like it should be the other way around, you're more likely to lose, you know,
the first half of the level you collect, but then by the second half of the level,
that's when it gets harder and you're going to lose those power-ups.
I feel like if you don't have any chance to get them, it feels a little...
That's definitely not the design decision that they were...
I think it's very intentional that they're sort of loading you up on supplies to begin.
Yeah, but then one hit and it doesn't matter.
And I feel like that just felt weird to me, that it wasn't, you know...
Well, there's always, you know, there's destructible areas, too, throughout the stage
that don't necessarily, like, imply that they have power-ups,
but if you shoot at them, they might give power-ups to you as well.
So I would say that it's definitely more generous than Gradius
because I think Gradius was only ever in the beginning of the stage, as far as I can remember.
Yeah, I can't remember. But, you know, that ties into another thing here is that while Gradius isn't impossible by any means,
it was something we thought, like, needed the Konami code.
You know, the up, up, down, down, left, right, left, right, BA.
In this one, I feel like if you have the Konami code, you're pretty much guaranteed a victory
provided you've at least seen the stages before.
Yeah. You know, it's very hard to consider losing 30 lives in Life Force.
In Gradius, that could have just been any given day
because you will go back to the destined checkpoint.
That's why I thought that this game, Life Force, was a much bigger power trip than Gradius.
And I think Life Force is not...
It shouldn't be punished for being easier
because I think in the world of NES games,
sometimes being easier on this kind of scale makes it a more accessible game.
Yeah. Whereas even though Gradius is on our essential games list,
some people might play that and think, like,
well, I just suck at shmups.
It's like, no, it just takes a lot of time and stuff like that.
Maybe you should try Life Force first to get better.
I was going to say, there's actually an argument to try the sequel first
because it feels like the natural progression is the other way around.
The difficulty, like, it's like the next level of difficulty is Gradius.
Okay. If you're going for that route.
Yeah, yeah. I mean, it's not that it has to be that way.
I mean, obviously, the events of Life Force take place after Gradius.
And you really want to probably get invested in the plot.
Now, Sean, to keep us grounded in this sci-fi world,
you're currently going through a Mass Effect playthrough
and you've played one and two and you're on three now.
Having played them in the order of one, two, three...
So you should be playing two, one, three.
Right. In order of descending...
How good they are. Which is not usually a measurement of thing to play.
But what I meant was, in three, by that point,
and this can apply to any version of a game franchise,
you look back at one and you say,
well, I could only play one first.
I could never go to three.
And forget that Mass Effect is storyline-based.
But, you know, like a lot...
Even Uncharted for Joe here, right?
Yeah, yeah. People who play Uncharted 4 first might not love going back to Uncharted 1.
Okay, so that's...
Might not love it, you're saying, because it's aged.
But also, those are also both pretty story-driven games.
Whereas, like... I know, arguably, Radius is pretty story-driven.
Yeah, removing itself from story, though.
Yeah. In both of the examples that...
In all of the examples that we've said so far,
the gameplay itself, the moment-to-moment gameplay,
has gotten better over time, at least in my opinion.
Yeah, as far as...
Maybe a lot of the difficulty in Gradius has...
Also, maybe some of it comes from it not being as well of a designed game.
Well, that's what I was going to get at,
is that after having played Life Force for a while,
I did go back to Gradius to remember, you know,
a lot about the game and to talk about and compare it to Life Force here on the show.
And I was kind of surprised that a game that came out only two years ago,
comparatively, we're in 1988 now, it came out in 86,
at the end of 86,
I was surprised to see myself feeling like,
oh, well, I don't think I could go back.
I'm glad I played Gradius first.
You know, like, it's weird to think about that in the scope of NES games,
but that's how I felt.
I don't know. How do you... Did you guys go back to Gradius?
To be honest, when I first played this,
I kind of... I was like, wow, this is like Gradius a lot.
I didn't go back to play Gradius,
but I went back and watched it,
and I was like, wow, this actually does look a lot better than Gradius.
You know, because just my memory of Gradius
is a little distorted by my...
That all being said,
I think that there is one thing that Gradius sort of has a leg up
in terms of Life Force.
I noticed a lot more slowdown.
Absolutely. And I think that...
I mean, it's obviously a trade-off,
considering that there seem to be a lot more effects going on in Life Force,
but it's definitely a negative.
Also, yeah, not only is it a negative for that reason,
the game is already, by the three of us,
considered easy in the realm of shmups.
That makes it easier. And then slowdown,
especially because slowdown occurs much more frequently
when you are a fully powered-up unit,
that it almost helps you, like,
you know, in your lazy boy chair,
in your Vic Viper,
you're able to, like, see through space and time
and make perfect decisions.
I justify it to myself by, like,
oh, no, that's how powered up I am.
I can now see things happening in slow motion
and now I'm super reactive.
But, yeah, the slowdown was...
Even on one player was pretty bad.
And we didn't go too far into two-player,
but I can only imagine it gets pretty bad
with two players powered up on the screen.
Thankfully, in two-player,
you can only have one option each,
but that's still one more option
or one more source of DACA
than the previous, like, single-player.
Thank you.
So, Joe, you just mentioned the two-player there,
and in this one,
you get the chance to play simultaneously,
two players at the same time.
That's kind of cool for a shmup,
but we did just see that, right?
With Legendary Wings?
We did. Right.
And that was a Capcom.
I'm not saying, like...
Yeah. I know you're both confused.
We're both, like, looking at you.
I'm just saying it's not a novelty to us.
Like, this wasn't the first shmup
where it was like, wow, two people, you know,
helping each other out,
doing the thing. It's nice to see that maybe
they're kind of figuring this out, though.
Like, people would probably
rather play together.
I mean, it's harder together.
Yeah. But, I mean, maybe it's just me,
but I love, like, a co-op...
See, I don't like other people.
Well, I gathered that, but...
But in general, I love a co-op game
with people that aren't Sean.
This doesn't work here because...
And we touched upon this
while we were playing. The Vic Viper and the Road British,
or Lord British, as it's officially known,
they look...
They're the same exact ship design, too.
And I don't know. Could they fit the sprite work
to design a different-looking ship?
Maybe. But to just say,
oh, well, it's like a bluish-orange now
instead of blue. Like, not even to go full orange on it,
to be like, you know,
the color of Drive,
the 2011 film.
You know, just to be like
that orange and blue.
The Best Picture nominee.
Nine years running.
Honestly, I think that
the design of the ship
isn't so much like...
Yeah, you're right.
It's the design of the ship
coupled with the color palette swap.
It needs to be a bit more contrasty.
And also, there needs to...
When they're on top of each other,
that's even worse
because if you go in one direction,
you pretty much have, like,
did a card trick on yourself.
Like, which one was I looking at
before we crossed paths?
And it's just so difficult
to distinguish. And then also, Sean,
you mentioned that you can each
have one option.
But I think it's also important
to talk about just the power-up system
in general changing
because when you fight against...
You know, when you take down
five of those orange guys
to generate a power-up,
you still just get one.
You don't get two.
So you do have to work together
a little bit to decide
who gets the power-ups.
Yeah, you can't be selfish like Mike
and try and take all the power-ups,
but that's just going to have to be
how good at cooperative games you are.
I am just, you know,
to anybody who's listened to me
and Sean play the games,
you can tell I'm just very selfish
in general when it comes... You're the reason Sean
doesn't like other people.
Right. At least in his video games.
Yeah. I love NPCs.
Yeah. NPCs are my best friends.
Yeah. Yeah, and I don't know
if there's anything else to really add to the two-player mode
other than that. Like, there's no collision
between the ships, thankfully.
Yeah. Like, not that anybody
should be confused by that.
I don't think that...
Hopefully that would never be added.
I think it should. Into one of these games,
but that would be crazy
just to consider
all the other things
that are on screen, too.
Do you guys ever feel like there was too much on screen?
In two-player, yes.
Maybe in two-player, but in one player,
I felt like I never thought
there was too much on screen
except I was like, well, I guess the game
thinks there's too much. Like, I thought there was
too much on screen because I was noticing
the slowdown.
I guess the game knows best.
I was like, well, there's not...
Like, you know what I mean.
I only thought there was too much on screen
because it was slowing
the game down. I was like,
all right, let's get a little less on here.
But otherwise, I don't think I would have
been overwhelmed. Yeah, there was occasionally
times where I was a little bothered by...
Like, all the enemies in this game are great,
by the way. I think that's worth mentioning.
Like, anything that actually
comes at you and attacks you...
Come at me. ...is great.
No, no, I mean, like, we got the return
of the Moai heads
and we love them
and we got the...
We got the Gradius
core bosses
from the first game.
Three of them as, like, a sub-boss
in one of them and it even plays
the Gradius one music.
I thought that was, like, a nice touch.
Do you guys remember that moment?
I remember that moment so well.
Right. So, you know,
things like that. Like, all of the actual enemies
in this game are really cool
except for those things
that aren't even necessarily enemies.
They're just part of the world
that just vomit
every now and again.
Like, either flames
or the rocks that come out
or... Yeah, I could do
without the rocks. Or even the...
And there's, like, different types of rocks, too.
There's those ones that...
There's unbreakable rocks.
Right. There's the ones that, like,
fall from the ground
and will automatically kill you
even if you have a force field.
Yeah. Then there's the ones
that just, like, shoot out of these
what I imagine they think
are, like, geezers
or something. Like...
Geysers. Geysers, sure.
Geysers are old people.
You know, it's every day with me.
So there's nothing new here.
And before we move on
to everything else
that usually comes with a nostalgia episode,
I wanted to talk about
the final boss
because I noticed that
after you defeat
the salamander,
the thing that you actually
have to do is shoot the core.
Pretty cool. At the actual boss,
Zelos, who has done
absolutely nothing, will do absolutely nothing,
is totally not the threat
he's made out to be in the manual.
He's definitely not a bad dude.
But you can choose
to not destroy him.
I didn't know that.
And I actually did this
on my second complete playthrough.
I said, well, it didn't feel
like I had to shoot him.
The screen keeps scrolling.
So the screen keeps going.
And rather than get
to the point with the different gates
and everything to, like,
be frame perfect, the thing we hate,
instead, as soon as that passes,
you restart the level.
Oh. And it's like,
no, you better go kill him.
That's so weird.
It doesn't communicate
why or anything. It just restarts you
at the start of the level again.
And it's like, okay.
It's weird that they would even program it that way
because I don't think that there's...
It shouldn't scroll. ...any player at all
that would decide
not to shoot them
unless you read about it
on a wiki. Right.
Well, I actually became
that person, though.
I did not read about it
on a wiki. I just thought...
You just didn't shoot it. I just thought that
it was weird that the screen
implied scrolling
and I did hear something
about alternate endings.
So I thought, oh, maybe there is
an alternate ending if you don't...
Do they count that as an alternate ending?
No, it's not. I'll explain the alternate endings
in our sequels and spinoff section.
But I just thought
that was like a neat thing
that you could just avoid
killing the final boss
and instead of being
rewarded for that,
it will tell you, no, play the level again.
It's not like everything's empty now.
You have to go do everything again,
including defeating the salamander.
Okay. It would have been cool
if they had like a little alternate
little mini cutscene
for doing that
where you now joined
Zelos or like...
Right, right. Or that you just
look behind your...
Look over your shoulder
and like, oh, man.
Yeah. Totally forgot about that.
Well, there are...
There's... Before we do sequels
and spinoffs, I just want to talk about
some version differences.
So in the arcade,
we talked about this at the very beginning
of the show, it didn't let you
choose your power-ups.
Instead, it gave them
to you immediately on your pickup.
The levels are
completely different after the first one.
The first one's exactly the same.
You mean like even the theme
of the levels? The themes of the levels
are the thing that make it different.
They didn't have this living planet construct.
You know, it was just like
different areas of space.
So then did the theme...
If the theme wasn't there,
was it still the same types
of like environmental obstacles
where things would grow
out of the ceiling at you?
Same types of enemies
and the same bosses
for the most part. Some bosses were swapped out,
but for the most part, it was the same bosses
that you see here
in the NES version.
And in the arcade version,
you could have four options.
Oh, man. Well, that's just a...
I mean, that's just a processing power thing,
I think. So to be able to like
have four other ships
with you and just line them up
in a row, you could have five.
You could pretty much take up the whole screen
at the bottom just shooting lasers
up at everything else.
I don't know if we described
what options were
at all during this episode,
but everyone who's listening
would probably know. But yeah,
they're just like, imagine another ship
that doesn't get
a ship sprite, it just gets a blue orb.
And that also shoots
whatever you have
it does there as well. And it follows you
like a trail, like wherever you were
the last input ago.
And then the Famicom version,
which is renamed
to Life Force Salamander,
it's like it also has
the Salamander thing in there.
In that one,
you can have three options.
So I thought that was a little strange
that in the Famicom one,
you get the choice for three options,
but they limited it to two
in the NES one.
And I played through
the Famicom version
and I think that like
that's the version I'll continue to keep playing
because nothing about it
is different and the ability to have
three options instead of two
just makes you feel even better.
Honestly, if they told me you could have seven,
I'd be like, I want that version.
And this is the one
that has different endings.
So at the end of the game
in the NES one,
it cuts to the Konami logo.
In this one,
it shows like a little
sprite work thing
before the Konami logo.
And it all depends
on your number of continues.
So if you only continued,
if you didn't continue at all,
you get to see
whoever was piloting
the Vic Viper without their helmet.
Reminded me of like
a Metroid style ending.
If you used like
one to three continues,
you got to see like the planet.
And if you did
like more than three continues,
you just saw like your helmet.
Just the helmet. Like just the helmet
placed down on like a surface.
Okay. With like some drop shadow.
I wouldn't say that
either of those
are better than the others.
I would say the helmet kind of seems really cool.
The helmet reminds me of like Mega Man,
which we haven't gotten
to the later Mega Man games.
But there's like one
in like I think Mega Man 3's ending
where he just like, you just see his helmet
in a field. And it's like,
that's pretty cool. Sort of like in Final Fantasy 7,
if you get a game over,
you get that. Yeah, the sword, right?
Broken or something like that.
Yeah, I actually now thinking about it too,
it's probably harder for them to make
a person look cool
as it is to just
a helmet look cool.
The helmet probably looks better than without
the helmet off. And I have
one developer
interview thing here,
which I thought
was kind of important.
I'll get it up here
because I don't know
who said it.
He just goes by the name Aki.
Ah. And no last name here,
but he says that
he was the programmer
on Salamander.
I don't know why I made that sound
like his name.
Do you believe him?
Yeah. He definitely was
the programmer on Salamander.
And I just grabbed
this quote. He says a lot of things
and also... Again, doubting him.
Right. No, but basically
like everything else that these guys say
is like they're huge Gradius fanboys
and they talk about like I used to go
to the arcade and I would bring
my tape cassette recorder
and record the music
just so I could listen to it.
And yeah, the arcade was loud
and it had my sound effects,
but I would listen to that thing all the time.
And, you know, it's like you guys
worked on these games. Like you don't have
access to the CDs
or the audio files themselves.
Well, because they did release all of...
Gradius' music is very
iconic, I guess,
to the Japanese.
So they did get
official releases of all of the audio
for all of the games
way back in the day.
Yeah. Anyway, to get to the point
of what he said, for the programming,
Salamander's PCB, which is their board
for the arcade,
didn't have a test mode
for debugging.
So you couldn't like make yourself
invincible and just test out
the levels. So in order to check
if everything was arcade accurate,
when it came time
to check the later loops,
I had to practice enough
to be able to get there
on my own. So they had to figure out
like how many loops
can the game go? Like we have to keep,
you know, like what does it look like
on loop seven? Like, you know,
I think that's like
the most bizarre thing
to make that decision.
Did they work on the boards? It's kind of like how
you can't upload like a Mario Maker level
until you beat it. It's like they have to
become masters of the game
before they can sell the game.
Maybe it's better that they got to test
their game without being able to use cheats.
Yeah. But they were able
to use the Konami code.
That's true. Yeah.
The creator of the Konami code
did just pass away
pretty recently. his name was
Kazuhisa Hashimoto.
And he started it
with Gradius actually,
which is the first instance
of it. Came up in all
the Gradius games. Also showed up in Contra,
another essential game
from us. So, you know,
I think we all have used that cheat
at one point or another
to help us. Shout out to Hashimoto.
Yep. And that is up, up,
down, down, left, right,
BA, and then start.
We'll be right back. Real quick, though,
I just want to tell you guys
for the sequels
and spinoff section, we kind of covered it
pretty in depth on the Gradius episode.
So there are many more
Gradius sequels to get to.
Listen to the Gradius episode
to find out the scoop
on all of those. Next up for us
will be Gradius 2
with Roman numerals,
not the numeric.
Whatever. You get the idea.
There won't be a number. It'll be Roman numerals
because this takes place
in the age after numbers.
I love that age.
And Salamander 2
did happen.
Okay? It's worth noting
that there was a Salamander 2,
came to the arcades,
and I think maybe the PS2
or PS1
in, like, 1996.
That would definitely be a PS1.
And it's, I don't know why,
but, like, it doesn't look great.
Like, I'm sure it was just like,
I have a, I should,
full disclosure. You does have a bias
against PS1 games.
I have a problem with not only just PS1 games,
now it's N64 games
and Saturn games.
It's charming.
We're not going to have this conversation again.
Early 3D for me
just doesn't do that low-poly stuff.
I can't handle it.
So there's something
about that. Maybe the game control
is just fine. I would like to get my hands
on Salamander 2,
so I will report back,
I guess, on the Twitter if anything turns out on that,
if I get the chance to play it.
Yeah. And while Sean laughs it off,
I've basically been
stumbling through the episode
and we are going to stumble
through the Essential Games list.
We have four Essential Games
from Konami already.
That is the same amount
as Nintendo R&D 1.
If we vote Life Force
into the Essential Games list
today, does that mean that Konami
is doing this system better
than its own maker?
They didn't...
Nintendo didn't make
Konami.
No, no, I meant the NES.
Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, like, is that controversial
to have, like, at any point in time
more Essential Games?
Well, I mean, like, if you count
the other Nintendo R&Ds,
technically, they're at, like,
six, seven?
They're at seven? So it's not like...
I guess it's still okay.
We're still safe. No one's going to write in
angry letters to us
that we're Konami fanboys
because we can't be fanboys
of pachinko machines.
It's just impossible. Honestly, arrest Konami.
Yeah, seriously.
Get down there
and do it. But right now,
we're not going to
arrest anybody
or at least the three of us
because we have a vote to do.
So, Joe, take us through
your Essential Games list
vote for Life Force.
One thing you might have noticed
is that this was
a whole episode
about shmups
and I didn't complain about it.
And I usually complain
about shmups and that really says a lot
to me. And I think I said
a similar thing when we talked about Gradius.
But I really do think
this is a very well-designed game.
Whether or not
it's better than Gradius,
I mean, playing it now,
I feel like it is,
but I am far removed
from Gradius. So I'd have to go back
and play it to really confirm
that that's my opinion.
But just the fact
that it also has a co-op,
which is a big plus for me,
a co-op for a good game
on the NES, which we had with Contra,
but we haven't had
a ton of good
cooperative experiences.
This one's fun,
single player or co-op.
So I don't know
if you can tell, but I'm going to vote
this essential.
All right. That's one vote.
What are we?
It's two, right?
I think you need two votes.
Two votes? Two votes, Mike.
Okay. All right.
So Joe didn't just
make it essential. We need to have
at least one other person
One out of three should be the new vote.
Sean? So, you know,
I know that this is
a very similar game
to Gradius.
And is it uniqueness
that makes the experience better?
Is it just raw gameplay
that should say
if it's essential or not?
And I think that this is
a more fun experience
than Gradius.
It's not as iconic.
That would, that's not really possible
when you have something
as iconic as Gradius.
But I did have more fun with it.
And I don't know
if that's because of tweaks
to difficulty
or a more creative level design,
even, you know,
warts and all. But I did have a lot of fun
with this game. And I think even though
maybe Konami's a little heavy,
a little heavy on the EGL right now,
I can't really hold it against them
for making good games.
So I'm going to vote it
onto the Essential Games list.
All right. So it is officially
on the Essential Games list,
but I will just add
that I love this game.
I think it's really,
really, really good. And Gradius was my top game
of 1986. I think it was most of ours
for 1986.
And I think of this
as one of those moments
where it's like, you know,
now that we exist in 2020
and we know everything
about like the NES library,
like we know of the good games
and we know what's coming up.
I bowled some of the ones
that I think are more important.
You can kind of see
that as cheating. But like in a way,
this was a very organic experience
because none of us
had heard of Life Force before, right?
Like I bowled at it
because I knew it was important
as a shmup,
but I had never played it before.
I never watched videos.
I don't spoil the experience
of doing the podcast itself here.
And so this was a very cool thing
where you play a game like Gradius
and that was my first time playing it.
And I loved it.
And I immediately voted
onto the Essential Games list.
I made my top game of 1986.
And it kind of got me
into a genre that I didn't like
think about too much before.
And now I play a lot of those shmup games.
Because we have to. Yeah, because we have to.
But I also dabble in
like some other consoles
that we don't have to.
Extracurricular shmups.
That's true. And to play Life Force
was a treat
because of having Gradius
in my knowledge bank.
I think if you weren't
going through
every NES game ever
in chronological order,
you might not appreciate
a game like Life Force
when it actually comes up.
If that's the first game
you play on the NES today,
you might not think it's anything too special.
But in the spectrum
of everything that we're doing here,
not only do I think
this is my favorite shmup
on the console now,
I think it's also
one of my favorite games.
And it has so much to do
with every other game
we've played before it.
But I think it really
understands a couple of things.
It gets the graphics right
in a way that doesn't
it doesn't hinder
the rest of the experience.
Sometimes we get
great looking games
that as a result,
the gameplay itself sucks
because they spend so much time on the pixel art.
You have to remember we're dealing with teams
of like six
making these NES games.
It's not like 200 people
working on a AAA game
like today. So the resources
are divided.
So to get a game that hits like all five
areas of what I consider
important is like
damn, that's got to be
on the essential games list.
And so that's why I'm putting Life Force
Interesting. I thought you were going to dissent.
Yeah. No, I have to.
It's got to be on there
and that does make
Konami with the perfect
five now
because that's all like I said
if it hits all five corners
because it can't
because there's only four corners
so it just created a fifth.
And I'm talking in a circle.
Pentagon's have five corners.
Let me escape. Nope.
All right. We're talking about corners now.
What are your thoughts on geometry?
I will say that
just to keep things
going here for the essential games list
there's nothing that because now
Life Force is on here
like Gradius
needs to be removed.
No one's saying that. Whether it happens or not
that's to be decided
in our Best of 88 episode.
I think it's just worth noting
that we've talked about
in the past of like
well games might be better
or I know games
are going to be better but right now
this is a good game so it has to be
on the essential games list.
I'm not gaming
the essential games list.
It's not something
I'm interested in. I liken it to
you know well once we put
Super Mario Bros. 3
on the essential games list
we just have to get rid
of Super Mario Bros. 1 right?
No. I thought about this a lot
when I was playing this game
because again I'll have to play Gradius again
but I know we've
kind of like mentioned
things like that before but I really think
yeah they can just both
be independently good games
and one can be better than the other
but they can both be essential for different reasons
both the games that you should play
and probably will enjoy.
Right. And that about
wraps it up for the
oh no it doesn't
because I forgot something fun
I wanted to mention. We covered the wrong game.
Yeah. We were supposed to
talk about Salamander. No no no
one real fun thing
that I wanted to mention is that Salamander
does have a
OVA anime
that you can watch
on YouTube which it's already
like the subtitles are burned in
and it is like
three 50 minute episodes
of original animation
that the first episode
just takes you through the entire plot
of Salamander.
Okay but I read about
this on Wikipedia.
I watched it. And yeah I didn't
I didn't watch it but the way that it was
written about on Wikipedia
was hilarious to me
because like again here's a game
that in both of them
really more so
in Life Force the plot is
incomprehensible and they use words
that don't mean anything
and they
they described
the anime
as not being
canon. And I just don't
understand how something like this
can have canon
or how canon
can be that like
untouchable.
Well yeah I agree
with the how can canon
be so untouchable
statement. I would say
that definitely
right now no one was
thinking about the deep lore
but you know
as Gradius evolves
as a franchise I mean it goes
all the way to Gradius 5
right? Like sooner or later
unlike the
When did the anime come out?
Who knows? No the anime
came out in like 86 so you're right
like who cares but like
I guess what I mean
is that it's not weird
for these games
like I'll give you
the perfect example to go back to
Super Mario Brothers I think it's weird
that there are people out there
trying to create a timeline
for when all
the Super Mario Brothers games
happen like I just
think that's ridiculous
right? But with Gradius
if the actual
like company
puts out like
actual years
to the dates
after the fact
I think that
helps dictate like what is
canon and what isn't.
Okay so word
of God is it rules
is that what is that's what
you mean? I think I mean
that if yeah if the actual
creator says something that
makes it legitimate
and that's why
the Disney movie
the Disney Star Wars
movies are not
real they don't
count because they're not
George Lucas's
idea. Well I think
that we can
have this discussion about
death of the author if we
want but we
should probably end the episode.
Yeah the episode ends with me
telling you that you can go to
our Twitter at NostalgiaCast
and write to us
about this episode
did you think Life Force was
essential? Have you ever
played Salamander?
What's an option?
Let us know
all of your thoughts on all
of this stuff just tweeted us
at NostalgiaCast
we're posting a lot
of cool stuff up on there it doesn't
have to be just for the game of
the week I've
learned how to make Twitter
threads now so
I make threads
to connect all
of the posts
for the same
game so this way
if you ever find one post
about Gauntlet you'll see all
of the Gauntlet stuff we've
posted. And while you're
on there don't
be afraid to muse to yourself
of whether a story is
more just something that
the author is
dictating or if
it's more a conversation between
the author and
the reader maybe you can
think about that
yeah you could think about that
or you could also tell your
friends about this
podcast that's the best way to
support us some people want
to know how can
I give you guys money that's great
I'm not going to
tell you that right here but if you
just mail something
out with my name on it maybe it'll
get to me so just write
to Mike and see if it
happens I would
say that forget
about the money and instead gain
us a listener that would be the
best thing you could possibly do
pay someone to
listen to us instead of paying
us the money we've grown a lot
since the beginning of the podcast
and we're very happy about that
but that only happens because of
you guys every
now and again somebody will post
about it on like Reddit or tweet
at us that they're going through
everything again
I'd like to for
you guys to think of yourselves in
the 80s or 90s
and think of this
podcast as a chain
letter and your
most getting in on
the ground level yeah you're no your
hopes will not come
true unless you
share this with however many people
or if you really
want to make it like the 80s or 90s
instead think of
nostalgia as like
something that you could listen to on
cassette and record
the episodes on a
cassette yourself and
then trade those
cassettes with other
people so this way
they can hear a nostalgia cast on
cassette the one
problem about that is we can't track
cassette plays currently we're
working on that technology but we're
not able to do it right now so you
won't really get credit for an
additional listener and we are giving
out credits for
a lot of credit you could say that
like the audio is
much warmer when
it's on cassette though yeah and
I'm sure in college you we we we give
out credits for
listening to this you can you can
theoretically graduate
from listening to
nostalgia the venn diagram
of people the
venn diagram of people who listen
to this show and
watch the show mad men is
probably very like
they're probably very close together
I would imagine that that middle
circle is actually gigantic usually
venn diagrams show
like a very small
circle in the middle and so I would like
to for you all to think of yourselves
as the Don Draper of
your own life and
and what you should really do is start
thinking about yourself as a
marketer for a
nostalgia cast how
can I sell the
show to my friends my mom's
never played video
games before why should she listen
nostalgia cast it's
toasted there you
go that's all you
have to say or
nostalgia cast it's a
podcast about playing
every NES game in
chronological order
that's the log line
moon moon moon! moon!